congratulations on such a successful
series
hats off to you so when the series
started it was basically an underdog and
then it turned into this superstar
now the heist is coming to an end
how do you feel sitting here doing press
for the last season
yes i'm more nervous than ever i must
confess i have done several promos of
the different seasons and you always try
not to be influenced by thinking too
much about the audience in order to be
able to bring out the best creativity
as regards your character but um in this
case when facing this last season i must
confess that i can't stop thinking i
couldn't stop thinking about the
audience
and trying to meet your expectations
it's a
sensation of vertigo because obviously
we're facing the ending and we want to
live up to the expectations
this is our last dance fairy make it a
good one
right
now you have nothing to be worried about
girl because we love you the audience
loves you oh thank you love you too
speaking of that jose
people were mad at your character for
killing nairobi last season so outside
of filming did you receive any comments
personally after that happened
yes i have uh received some negative
comments and also a couple of death
threats but i was also warned about my
colleagues they told me to be ready for
what was coming
but i must say that even so the majority
of the comments i have received were
positive because at the end of the day
people love this kind of character who
has no scruples whatsoever and who has
this kind of dark code how do you feel
ursula overall how do you feel about how
the show ended i know director alex pina
says that
he promised this will be the most
extinct and epic season yet
how do you feel about how the story
ended
i
must say to be honest that i feel quite
relieved
during the last day of filming i
remember that i was weeping and i was
extremely sad but when i was all cried
out and i was brought to flowers and i
left the set i remember thinking to
myself wow i have survived
the filming of money heist
and many heavy things have happened
since the beginning of this series and
making this series entailed a big risk
so without giving any spoiler i must say
that i am happy with the way things have
ended with my character the rest of the
characters and the series if you could
revisit your characters i know you all
said goodbye to them for now if you
could revisit them where would you like
to see them
interesting
see
in the case of
many characters they have spent many
years in the series whereas in my case
there is a few hours worth of trajectory
and only in one situation so
i haven't gotten to know gandia that
well beyond those hundreds hundred hours
i don't know how he behaves outside the
realm from work or out there with his
colleagues going out for a drink
so i don't know how he would be really
but i also think it is important the way
he is written in the script i stick to
my lines i stick to my script and based
on that i create the characters
por que in my case i have difficulty
picturing tokyo as a calm person
if i were to imagine her
from the standpoint of me being ursula
and tokyo being my friend i would wish
for her to be in a calm state
uh kept outside of any danger in a state
of maturity and enjoying life a bit more
but as a viewer and probably as an
actress if i had to play her again i
would picture her as a troublemaker
because i believe that's where her spark
lies that's where making that's what
makes her happy and i think that in
reality she's addicted to that
you